tren flores en el brillo de su
imputación así tituló el periódico New
York Times en la víspera del juicio del
expresidente estadounidense que ha sido
imputado en un caso de dinero pagado a
la actriz porno Storm y Daniels antes de
las elecciones de 2016 una acusación que
no parece preocupar al multimillonario
por su Imagen nunca ha tenido tanto
apoyo y amor como ahora contra los
insurrectos de la izquierda radical
extorsionadores políticos torcidos y
matones que están destruyendo nuestro
país gracias haremos América grande de
nuevo Mientras tanto según sus abogados
Donald Trump se prepara para la batalla
el domingo su equipo legal insistió que
el expresidente estaba en el punto de
mira por ser un candidato presidencial
en las elecciones de 2024 una opinión
compartida por su simpatizantes que se
reunieron frente a su club de golf en
Florida para saludarlo estaremos Detrás
de él Creo que si tiene que ir a la
cárcel solo va a aumentar su apoyo y
entonces todo el mundo va a caer
buena suerte a los verdaderos criminales
buena suerte el expresidente de Estados
Unidos volvió a pedir a sus seguidores
que contribuyeran con dinero a su
campaña de reelección de 2024 el viernes
se supo que la campaña de Trump ya había
recaudado 4 millones de dólares en las
primeras 24 horas tras conocerse su
imputación